a chi non piacerebbe avere un robot in
casa che parla magari fa le pulizie voi
piacerebbe penso a tanti magari come
questo
alzate le mani per favore se vi piace a
chi li piace non ne vedo nemmeno una
qualcuno starà pensando che magari un po
troppo realistico allora uno un po meno
realistico come questo
alzate la mano per favore
nemmeno una questo ad esempio ha dei
tratti umani ma che sono semplificati
vediamone un altro questo si sa se la
mano e vedo tante mani alzate
va bene ecco ma cos'è che ci fa avere
paura di quelli che alla fine sono
oggetti c'è una teoria a riguardo
si chiama è data è un'ipotesi l'ipotesi
dell'anca nivali in italiano la valle
perturbante se poniamo sull'asse delle
ascisse la verosimiglianza con l'essere
umano sull'asse delle ordinate la
familiarità che proviamo
abbiamo le ipotesi dice che abbiamo una
curva che a questa forma ossia un robot
essere una scatola di metallo
man mano che ha fattezze sempre più
umane noi proviamo più familiarità
empatia verso di esso fino a un certo
punto in cui nella curva troviamo la
valle la valle in fondo a questa vale
troviamo dei magari capolavori di
ricerca come quelli che vi ho mostrato
che però essendo simili all'essere umano
essendo quasi essere umano quel quasi è
sinonimo di qualcosa che non quadra e
cos'è che non quadra nel fondo della
valle possono essere dimensioni distorte
come il caso di sibi su un robot bambino
di 12 anni
o parti meccaniche miss tea party che
sembrano organiche oppure dettagli che
non corrispondono alle nostre
aspettative o meglio alle aspettative
del nostro cervello
tutte queste cose e la l'ambiguita in
sede alla somiglianza possono rendere un
robot inquietante ma c'è di più c'è un
motivo ancora più profondo e radicato
nel nostro passato
sicuramente tutti voi conoscerete film
di fantascienza un caso famoso è quello
di terminator
in molti di questi una storia comune è
sempre quella dei robot che a un certo
punto si ribellano e cercano di
sterminare l'umanità tipico però questa
non è una prerogativa dei robot perché
già esisteva una storia precedente che
conosciamo bene quella di pinocchio un
umano artificiale che a un certo punto
va fuori controllo e prima ancora
dall'inizio dell'ottocento
la storia di frankenstein cui la
creatura altro un'altra volta una
creatura artificiale va fuori controllo
e per questo viene chiamato complesso di
frankenstein bene ad esempio questo
complesso non esiste in giappone
in giappone i robot sono visti spesso
come eroi che salvano l'umanità e hanno
sentimenti un'anima e questa che vedete
è una statua alta 20 metri che è
presente in una piazza a tokyo
ma allora noi questa paura da dove
l'abbiamo presa la nostra cultura deriva
dall'antica grecia e nella mitologia
greca
c'erano tante storie riguarda
l'automazione come quella del pigmalione
in cui egli scolpì un uomo che scolpì la
una statua di una donna e si innamorò di
essa però non c'era niente di negativo
in questa storia e in tutte queste
storie di automazione
quindi non abbiamo preso questa paura
evidentemente dalla cultura greca per
paragone vediamo anche in cina per
millenni hanno inventato loro gli
spettacoli di ombre cinesi in cui queste
marionette prendevano vita grazie ai
movimenti di file alle giunture
ebbene allora non lo sappiamo con
certezza ma probabilmente la prima
storia di questo genere di questa paura
è la storia del golem fin dall'età
medievale e poi nel 1600 che una storia
di eredità ebraica questa storia i golem
una creatura fatta di argilla creata da
un rabbino una creatura che non poteva
né parlare né pensare andò a fuori
controllo
dovete essere distrutta e questo è un
esempio di più brees cioè della superbia
in questo caso dell'uomo nel voler
creare qualcosa di vivo artificiale
quindi vedendo complessivamente
occidente oriente hanno radici molto
lontane tra di loro ma da ambo le parti
abbiamo storie di umani artificiali e
nel presente però abbiamo da una parte
il complesso di frankenstein
dall'altra parte un immagine positiva
cosa è successo nel mezzo che ha portato
a questa di versione
una possibile spiegazione è l'influenza
delle religioni perché nelle religioni
monoteistiche
c'è una distinzione netta tra il
naturale e l'artificiale quello che ha
creato da dio
quello che non è stato creato da dio
creato dall'uomo nelle regioni orientali
ispirate al confucianesimo influenzate
dalla confucianesimo ogni oggetto ha
un'anima
e torniamo al presente io ho lavorato e
studiato tanti anni a tokyo
questo è robot con cui ho lavorato un
umanoide molto avanzato che però a volte
mi ricordava qualcosa bene disegnato da
ingegneri forse è proprio questo è il
punto
perché piuttosto che disegnare questi
robot soltanto in base alla loro
funzionalità
forse dovremmo ispirarci al design al
proprio al campo del design come fa la
apple ad esempio che è un'azienda che ha
saputo trarre vantaggio dall unione tra
tecnologia e design
loro si sono avvalsi di un concetto
design chiamato schermo wrf ismo la
parola schermo il fismo deriva dal greco
significa da scales contenitore e morph
e devo dire forma significa creare un
nuovo oggetto con l'apparenza con
l'aspetto di un oggetto che esiste già
con cui l'utente già familiare e
applicato a un'applicazione come la
libreria alla sinistra vedete come era
disegnata nelle prime versioni della us
cioè con l'aspetto di uno scaffale di
legno poi successivamente quando hanno
pensato evidentemente che gli utenti
ormai si erano abituati
sono passati e un'interfaccia flat ma
disegnare robot in base a questo
concetto che cosa comporta
perché i robot sono possibilmente
l'oggetto tecnologico più complesso che
esiste perché sono lo specchio dell'uomo
allora se sono uno specchio di un uomo
evidentemente come abbiamo visto in
precedenza parlando di cultura dobbiamo
considerare la nostra cultura il nostro
passato nel modo in cui disegniamo se ci
pensate
le automobili sono personalizzate per i
diversi mercati del mondo così come
tanti altri oggetti in vendita
allora a maggior ragione i robot devono
essere personalizzati
e non possiamo prescindere da nella
cultura
da considerare anche la religione che la
improntata questa foto l'ho scattata
all'isola di pasqua e fa vedere proprio
emblema ticamente 1 ae con una croce
quindi il padano con il sacro
vediamo un esempio il dharma questo qui
a destra è un talismano di buona sorte
protezione presente che proveniente dal
buddismo e molto comune quindi nella
cultura anche sia in giappone anche in
cina e questo aiuta perché ci crede a
realizzare i propri desideri che li
nella foto stanno tutti scritti nei
bigliettini a sinistra il dharma in
generale è un oggetto di piccole
dimensioni che molti giapponesi tengono
in casa allora prendendo questo come
modello come ispirazione tramite schermo
wrf ismo abbiamo realizzato un piccolo
robot sociale per la compagnia degli
anziani che assume l'identità del dharma
e questo io l'ho portato in un ospizio
in diversi ospizi in giappone o almeno
un prototipo di questo e gli anziani
come tutti sapete non sono propriamente
amanti delle nuove tecnologie ne sono
abbastanza intimoriti e quelle
giapponesi non fanno eccezione
però questo d'arma parlante non li a
intimoriti perché è qualcosa che
conoscono già presente nel loro passato
quindi abbiamo probabilmente con
successo utilizzato la revisione
all'interno del design di tecnologia ma
revisione tecnologia non sono campi uno
all'opposto dell'altro non sono uno
contro l'altro
in realtà no la religione non è per
definizione contro la tecnologia perché
anche la revisione si è evoluta passando
da la tradizione orale all'età lezione
scritta
alla stampa ai mass media e presto potrà
trarre beneficio dalle nuove tecnologie
come intelligenza artificiale per
facilitare la diffusione e la robotica
anch'essa a delle origini molto antiche
che si intersecano con quelle delle
religioni e leone di alessandria nel
italianistica disegnò diversi automata
così venivano chiamati dei marchingegni
che eseguivano dei movimenti e questi
venivano molto spesso messi dentro
templi come l'altare a dioniso che lui
disegna e in epoche successive
il maggior sforzo che di queste opere di
questi automat indovinate chi era la
chiesa cattolica alla ricerca di mezzi
per impressionare i fedeli quello che
vedete nel mezzo ed il monaco meccanico
commissionato come opera votiva da
filippo ii di spagna nel 1560 e da altre
parti del mondo
ad esempio in india da millenni si usano
marionette durante le festività indù e
in giappone in epoche successive con
l'invenzione dei primi auto amata queste
chiamate bambole karakuri venivano poste
anche all'interno dei templi in generale
per rappresentare il tema religioso si
fa uso della bellezza se fa uso
dell'arte dell'arte sacra e ad esempio
la sezione aurea è un concetto che è
molto utilizzato ed è frequentemente si
può trovare frequentemente in molti e
opere in molte opere rinascimentali ad
esempio di una certa importanza
religiosa e come dice il corano
dio è bello e ama la bellezza perché
l'arte sacra non è soltanto l'arte
un'arte che ha per tema qualcosa di
sacro ma
è intrinsecamente sacra perché tramite
la bellezza trasmette il concetto di
divino quindi allora forse abbiamo la
chiave usiamo lo schermo orfismo
ispirandoci all'arte sacra per portare
qualcosa di familiare e in italia siamo
pieni di arte sacra nei luoghi più
impensabili
io ho un tempo non ci facevo caso
vivendo a livorno ma abituando mi ad
altri paesaggi urbani
adesso che torno mi saltano all'occhio
molti dettagli tra cui ad esempio un
elemento decorativo molto diffuso sono
dei santi in una nicchia come potete
vedere in queste foto scattate anche a
livorno e questi santini non hanno
soltanto una funzione decorativa perché
sono proprio un oggetto di conforto per
per un credente perché fanno da
intermediario con dio e perché
contengono incorporano simboli bene
basandoci su questo
su questa ispirazione vi presento il
primo robot cattolico dai tempi di
filippo ii di spagna
o forse sarebbe meglio chiamarlo un
santo interattivo perché altro non è che
un opera d arte sacra con delle
funzionalità innovative e vista
l'occasione l'ho anche portato
con molta delicatezza perché è sacro
questo è stato disegnato tenendo conto
appunto dei canoni di bellezza e
ispirandosi all architettura neoclassica
e contiene delle dimensioni di sezione
aurea e si accende semplicemente ponendo
una candela elettronica e toccandogli le
mani non ha altre interfacce come
schermi telecomandi i bottoni diavolerie
elettroniche di sorta e le componenti
elettroniche come i motori la il
microfono gli speaker sono tutti i
contenuti sono mascherati da
dall'apparenza quindi sono sono nascosti
dentro dentro il corpo del santo e
dentro la nicchia e in quante contenuti
questo contiene storie di vite dei santi
sermoni preghiere può contenere un
database di di queste tutte queste cose
che lo rendono un compagno un plausibile
compagno per la preghiera per tante
persone anziane o sole che ne hanno
bisogno e io l'ho portato in un ospizio
in germania questa è una foto in cui
stanno pregando insieme il padre nostro
quindi per concludere i robot sono
oggetti complessi perché come la
complesso l'uomo però il robot sono
all'orizzonte
dobbiamo decidere ora come crearli per
fare in modo che siano socialmente
accettabili e perché siano accettabili
serve che siano familiari perché siano
familiari dobbiamo ispirarci alla nostra
cultura il nostro passato e se
esaminiamo alla cultura
dobbiamo anche considerare la religione
e se tocchiamo la revisione dobbiamo
anche riesaminare di studiarci i canoni
di
bellezza e finisco con un invito in
italia siamo stati il centro
dell'umanesimo quindi il centro dello
studio dell'uomo e non solo siamo i
maestri dell'arte nel mondo
e inoltre abbiamo istituti
all'avanguardia nella ricerca in
robotica e nuove tecnologie
allora con questi tre elementi dico io
creiamo lì noi italiani questi robot
accettabili e soprattutto belli che
rispecchino il nostro passato grazie